claude blanchemaison bonjour jours
heureux de vous retrouver dans la
matinale de rtl france alors que à faire
anthony blinken à jérusalem et à
ramallah
tout d'abord à jérusalem il va
évidemment rencontré le premier ministre
benyamin nétanyahou non pas pour leurs
assurés parce qu'il n'a pas assuré il a
vu qu'elle était le comportement de joe
biden pendant la crise
joe biden à protéger israël en utilisant
à trois reprises le veto au conseil de
sécurité des nations unies et et
s'opposer une résolution demandant
imposant la paix en fait imposant le
cessez le feu mais elle y va évidemment
rappelé le soutien inconditionnel des
états unis à la sécurité d'israël et le
soutien sur le plan politique le soutien
sur le plan du renseignement que
soutient également sur le plan des
fournitures de matériel militaire
je pense qu'il va aussi évidemment
discuté avec le premier ministre
netanyahu des suites probablement
s'informer sur la situation dans les
villes israéliennes où vivent les arabes
qui naturellement manifesté pendant
pendant la période de crise sur la
situation à jérusalem s est probablement
il parlera de l'étape suivante qui est
celle des contacts avec l'autorité
palestinienne et avec mahmoud abbas le
président le premier ministre d'état des
eaux va chercher à savoir si les
américains en ont un plan pour les
discussions politiques ultérieurs
mais très manifestement ce n'est pas
dans le mandat de tony blinken de
d'entrer dans le temps dans le détail
delà de la phase ultérieure et de
l'éventuelle fins politiques
pour ce qui est de l'étape de ramallah
qui va suivre
c'est assez important parce que ça va
permettre aux états unis de conforter
mahmoud abbas dont le prestige a été
un petit peu écornée par le fait que ce
soit le hamas qui apparaissent comme le
défenseur de la cause palestinienne
comme le parti qui pouvait résister
pendant dix jours aux attaques aériennes
israéliennes et lancer des roquettes sur
le territoire israélien et donc
effectivement monsieur blinken ne peux
pas parler au hamas puisque la masse est
considéré par les etats-unis comme une
organisation terroriste
donc il n'ira pas à gaza et il va
discuter avec mahmoud abbas à ramallah
de la suite y compris d'ailleurs de la
construction de la zone de gaza de la
bande de gaza puisque c'est maintenant
sur le sujet qui va être à l'ordre du
jour
toutes les infrastructures économiques
et sociales ont été détruites et par
conséquent il faut évidemment
reconstruire c'est d'ailleurs l'appel
qu'a lancé le secrétaire général des
nations unies donc cette étape de
ramallah est très importante car il faut
que les américains détermine avec le
président mahmoud abbas comment faire
comment faire pour intervenir à ramallah
où le fatah n'a pas ne peut pas ne peut
pas intervenir directement
alors que cette zone est contrôlée par
le hamas avec lequel les états unis
n'ont pas de relations directes
il faudra évidemment passer par les
organisations internationales qui elles
sont présentes dans la bande de gaza et
par les ong
justement claude quel impact peut avoir
les discussions avec mahmoud abbas en
parler avec le hamas comme vous nous
l'expliquer bien c'est la situation
c'est la difficulté que qu'on les les
états unis effectivement il ne pouvait
pas parler à
d2b légèrement et c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle en réalité le
cessez-le-feu a été négocié par l'egypte
par le président el sissi et par le roi
de jordanie abdallah ii
les états unis faisaient pression pour
qu'il y ait certainement là cessez le
feu mais il ne pouvait pas le négocier
puisqu'il peut pas parler à l'un des
deux belligérants
donc en effet il fallait passer par le
président el sissi et par le roi
abdallah c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle monsieur week-end se rend
également au caire et amman
après les étapes de jérusalem et du
ramallah et les oreilles qu'est-ce qui
va reconstruire la bande de gaza claude
alors il ya l'onu veille naturellement
vouloir coordonnées c'est tout à fait
légitime puisque il y a à ramallah une
agence de l'onu qui est spécialisée dans
l'aide aux réfugiés qui sont dans la
bande de gaza boudra les américains
d'ailleurs repris leur financement a le
bras que monsieur trump avait suspendu
c'est une bonne chose mais l'unrra ne
peut pas tout faire elle a des écoles
dans la vente d'armes dans la bande de
gaza elle a aussi des dispensaires je
vois que aussi que médecins sans
frontières va probablement organisé des
dispensaires ou revenir dans les
hôpitaux qui ont été détruits donc il va
falloir construire des hôpitaux
construire des écoles comme après chaque
guerre avec israël et sur ce sujet
l'union européenne est généralement très
généreuse et et faisaient était est
utile puisqu'elle participe à ces à ces
travaux ces actions de coopération pour
réhabiliter les infrastructures sociales
dont il est probable qu'il y aura une
conférence sur la façon de dd les
les populations de la bande de gaza et
que c'est à cette conférence on fera
appel aux donateurs aux grands donateurs
on sait déjà que l'egypte est intervenu
puisqu'elle peut envoyer de l'aide
humanitaire par un point de passage au
sud de la bande de gaza donc l'egypte
sera certainement très active en tant
que pays voisin qui contrôlent la
frontière sud
et puis l'europe les états unis le
canada et peut-être d'autres pays
voudront aider les la population de gaza
l'idée aussi sur le plan c'est le plus
urgent sur le plan humanitaire car
effectivement la population notamment
les enfants sont dans une situation
déplorable des fautes un programme
d'aidé alimentaire immédiat il faut un
problème sanitaire
parce que là aussi le co vide
la kfw 19,6 vie on n'a aucune
statistique mais il est probable que la
situation est tout à fait déplorable
dans la propulse dans cette population
qui vient de subir deux semaines de
guerre
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison pour
cet éclairage un édito à retrouver sur
les réseaux sociaux
je vous rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales